welcome to bananamores i can't even
contain my excitement for this next
comedian
all you people watching at home get
those hands of clapping
[Applause]
hey guys how are you
um introductions i guess
uh i'm tina and
i'm disabled
don't worry you're going to be okay
i am well i'm kind of disabled right
no not really though you know who
i'm kind of half and half like i'm not
totally committed to the lifestyle
of it kind of like
like the the bisexuality of abilities
right like i'm biable right
by bubbles a bit of an
enigma right like people will see me
and they don't know what's happening
you know they don't know what to say
but that doesn't stop them
so i get a lot of weird things saying to
me
like um you don't look like you should
be
disabled right like like it's a hogwarts
house
they would never let me into hogwarts by
the way it'd be
a huge liability you know like
you've got stairs that move like
like the ones have that kind of voice
activated
siri technology that i just do
not job with you know like
i don't i know that one miscommunication
and it would end up setting fire
to someone's esophagus
or something like that why can't you
compliment me
like a normal person you've got
so many options
and whenever i talk one time back in
like high school
i was in art class painting like a color
wheel
and a girl leaned over to me and she
said tina
it's so cool you're disabled
but you're actually good at this stuff
look what do you say to that
that is a common misconception
it's bucky that i'm actually good at all
this stuff right
i'm just particularly bad at being
disabled
how dare you know but
the thing is that like i used to think
that i would grow
out of this you know like
in my defense though for the molecular
amount of media representation that we
have today there was even
less of it back in the early 2000s
you know like back when i was a kid
we had nothing on tv like me
we had like drake in a wheelchair
that was it
i love making that reference oh god it
really divides the room
you guys you got right
not so much over here this guy
he doesn't even know where he
no but i'll all explain so back when i
was a kid
there was a channel on tv of course
team nick right which was nickelodeon
but for eight-year-olds with their
parents in the other room
right and there was kissing and
people died and it was powerful
okay and all that channel there was a
show
called grassy and onto grassy
there was a kid in a wheelchair
played by drake the rap
strike i'm not making okay
so naturally i thought that i would just
grow
up to be like
a rap mogul so
that's all i've come to say right now so
thanks to mercy i can't even get over
how much talent this person has the
banana more stage is
lucky to have that one i'll tell ya